Now, consider another sentence that we have come across earlier.
If an animal lays eggs, and it flies, then it is a bird. How do
we write this in the language of logic, given that there is conjunction here. So
this time, we can have two predicates again. There is a predicate of lays-eggs,
coming from here. The predicate of flies, coming from here. And
we can denote a conjunction between them. Which in the language of logic is
often put in this form. Now we can re-write this sentence in the following form.
If the animals lays eggs and the animal flies, then the animal is a bird.
Remember again, this semi colon here, really is denoting implication for
now. Remember again, that in logic, this really stands for an implication.
Consider the slightly different sentence. Suppose if the sentence was if
an animal lays eggs or it flies it is a bird. In that case, again,
we'll have two predicates, but this time we'll have a disjunction between them.
And the sentence would become or if animal lays eggs or animal flies,
then the animal is a bird. And again, this is an implication. Let us continue
with the our exercise in which we are learning how to write sentencable language
of logic. It is under the sentence, if an animal flies and is not a bird.
So, it is a negation here, then it is a bat. How do we write that in logic? So
I'm still interested in writing the antecedent of this particular sentence, and
I may be able to say that animal flies is a conjunction here,
because it is an and here, and we have this negation symbol for this predicate,
bird. Now we can write a complete sentence by saying that the animal flies,
conjunction. Animal is not a bird, implies animal is a bat.